so so far we haven't really done much
with data structures outside of Python
lists we looked at two dimensional lists
but you know there's still lists and so
this particular puzzle that we're going
to do today I has a graph structure
associated with it so for the first time
at least in this class we'll be looking
at traversing graphs and I we're gonna
do this in a recursive way and also
we'll have a graph representation by
using dictionaries so most of you have
probably seen dictionaries if you
haven't I'm going to explain them
they're essentially ways that you can
index into lists not just using nonzero
integers you know indices 0 through n or
what-have-you but things like strings or
tuples and so they're just more general
and they're more general data structure
then then Python lists and so they're
very convenient I when when it comes to
representing graphs and traversing
graphs so the puzzle we can look at is
as always a little bit contrived it's
about a weakened dinner scheduling so
you have a bunch of friends and let me
draw your social network here or
someone's social network so we won't
name names but each node in this graph
represents a friend and a couple more
and so that's the set of friends a
through H and it won't be particularly
interesting as a graph if it just had
nodes you want to add edges to it
what are these edges represent well you
like all of your friends but your
friends don't necessarily like each
other and so an edge between nodes so
nodes are friends and an edge between a
pair of nodes implies a dislike
relationship all right I'm so be dislike
see and it's symmetric you could argue
that dislikes is not necessarily
symmetric but we'll just call it that
that implies that C dislikes B as well
so this is not necessarily a directed
graph some of the time especially when
you're doing route planning going from
point A to point B you have to take into
account one way streets and so you'd
have directed graphs but many a time
you're you can get away with undirected
graphs so you just the existence of an
edge between B and C implies that in a
traversal you can get from B to C or C
to B and it there's no direction there
and so I'm gonna fill in the rest of
this and then get to the question that
we want to answer and so that's your
your friend graph and it also has these
six or seven dislike relationships and
your job is to well keep all your
friends happy i and at the way you're
going to do that is by is by having a
couple of parties on the weekend so this
is a regular weekend you know let's call
it the Friday and Saturday Friday and
Saturday night parties and that the only
constraint are actually there's two
constraints there's the two constraints
that you need to fall
are satisfied then you have these two
parties so you have your Friday party in
your Saturday party is you can't leave
anybody out right so you effectively the
constraint is on each friend comes to
exactly one party no one gets left out
no one comes to both so that's fair and
then the second constraint as you can
probably guess is no pair of friends who
dislike each other they're not friendly
they're your friends can be invited on
the same day
and so you want an algorithm that is
going to give you a schedule and
obviously the schedule is not
necessarily unique I mean if you had a
bunch of happy-go-lucky low overhead
friends you know they all like each
other and you can just randomly break
them up into two groups you can think of
it as a partition a partition this is a
grouping where then you have anything at
a set of nodes for example and you
partition it you're essentially saying
you're breaking it up into two groups
such that each node is in exactly one
group and each node and then you have
another property associated with the
partition that corresponds to the edges
between these nodes but we'll get to
that in just just a minute
yeah go ahead buddy so so the purpose of
this puzzle is to determine whether you
can actually do this or not
and so you are certainly welcome to when
you write a computer program or when we
write a computer program here it might
say no can do you know find a different
set of friends or maybe identify a
problem case you know this one person
who dislikes
all of your other friends maybe you
should drop that person right and so so
you can imagine that I that you would
not necessarily be able to satisfy these
two constraints for all graphs right and
so that's really the essence of the
puzzle for what kind of graphs and this
it turns out they're a fairly famous
kind of graph that's does this puzzle
have a solution right and so you you you
have to look at this and you kind of go
and the first thing that occurred to you
was hey if I had if
gah if I invite f1 Friday I have to
invite G and H on Saturday but then G
and H don't like each other right so
that's a problem right and so in this
particular case you've identified this
cycle that indicates that this problem
is not solvable but let's say that
somehow you've located G and you past
they've patched up alright so so you end
up having you know fairly complex graph
structure that looks like this right and
now what happens now is there is there a
solution to this problem this particular
puzzle I mean a can come on any day so
let's ignore a I is easy
suppose you invite you could try and
figure this out by saying let's let's go
ahead and invite invite be on on Friday
so what does that imply that immediately
implies that C is on Saturday right what
does that imply D is on Friday right so
you see you see how this is going to go
what does that imply enf are on are on
Saturday so I have e and F on Saturday
ok and then what does that imply the FFF
being on Saturday implies that G H and I
have to be on on Friday right and then I
don't forget a so let's just take a in
here to even things out
all right and so so we kind of did an
algorithm here we executed an algorithm
right and it it turns out that as graphs
that can be partitioned in this manner
are have a special name are they called
up bipartite graphs
bipartite graphs I'll write it out and
the the reason they call bipartite
graphs is if you have a bipartite graph
you can always draw it in this fashion
where you have a c EF and then you have
B D G H I such that you never see edges
like this or like that all the edges go
from left to right or right to left
they're undirected okay so that's really
a a bipartite graph and if I draw this
out oh don't need that C goes to B and D
it goes nowhere he goes to D and F goes
to a bunch of different places yeah so
you're allowed to have this would still
be about I want this is not the graph
that we had but it's not that the edges
can't be crossing edges okay they just
all have to go from left to right you
just can't have an edge between a and C
or C and a you can't have an edge
between D and H etc right so you you
want you have to be able to separate out
the nodes such that and they're no edges
in this set of nodes you know it's just
between these set of nodes and no edges
between that set of nodes and this is
just a topological property that I
cursed wants to bipartite graphs and
there's another property that
essentially is equivalent to our puzzle
which says bipartite graphs are
two colorable and it's obvious as to why
I buy but bipartite graph is two
colorable and what does it mean to be
two colorable well you need to color
each node with two colors in this case
Friday and Saturday such that no pair of
nodes with an edge between them have the
same color so exactly equivalent to what
we've talked about here so our goal now
is to discover whether a bipartite graph
I've already given graph excuse me is
bipartite or not once you know that a
graph is bipartite you know it's two
colorable you know it's a solution to
our to our problem to our puzzle problem
okay and of course in order to do this
and if you had a graph but you had
thousands of friends and perhaps tens of
thousands of edges and you need to
discover it's not your dinner problem
maybe but you need to discover whether
the graph is two colorable or not then
you need to write a computer program for
this you need a graph representation you
need to do this traversal etc etc go
ahead Josh I guess they're equivalent
different definitions absolutely right
because that what would happen is if you
can color it then it means that you can
take all of the red colors you read
could be equivalent to Friday and and in
blue could be equivalent to Saturday and
all of the red colors could be placed on
the left and and the the blue on the
right buddy
yes that's that that's that there's
always pathological cases and they're
usually things that get swept under the
rug but one colorable is is it is
considered too colorable you can color
it with two colors that's really what it
is let's talk about cycles to get a
sense for this property so immediately I
think you recognize that when you have
something like I figured what it was
exactly f GI or F G H whatever that if
you had a cycle like this
that a graph is not bipartite right the
three cycle is not bipartite is any
cycle a problem if I have a cycle in the
graph which means that I can go from one
node back to the same node through a
sequence of edges and obviously
traversing nodes do I have a problem is
that it can be immediately declared that
the graph is not bipartite
yeah go ahead Julia why not
ah yeah that's exactly what I wanted to
bring up so if I had something like ABCD
right
that's clearly a a cyclic graph and I I
could put um a and C out here and V and
D up here and clearly there's no edge
between a and C there's no edge between
B and D there's an edge between a and B
there's an edge between C and D and
there's also an edge between a and G and
C and B so as I mentioned you're allowed
crossing edges right they all have to go
from left to right or right to left
whichever way you're looking at it so
interesting enough and this is two
colorable on but when you get to when
you get to odd cycles so I'll draw one
out here in the middle and let's say I
want a mark these nodes the names but
let's say that you have a five cycle now
right if you have a five cycle think
about it you you you're going to go
color this red so let me just go ahead
and say this is red which means this
needs to be blue that needs to be blue
this blue implies this needs to be red
[ __ ] now implies that this needs to be
blue and it's like whoops that's a
problem right so interestingly enough
the odd evenness or the parody of a
cycle determines whether a graph is
bipartite or not it doesn't mean that
that I that a graph that only has four
cycles in it is is is necessarily
bipartite because they they could be
other reasons for it not to be not to be
bipartite because you know you don't
know but the other cycles in the graph
they could be you say it's only up to
four cycles well there could be a three
cycle in it and and things get pretty
complicated when you have things like
like that there's a lot of cycles in
here this is a cycle like that there's a
cycle like this and the moment you put
an edge in here now you're saying this
goes over here it goes like this
there's a three cycle here but even if
this didn't exist there would be a five
cycle etc etc so there's a lot of cycles
and graphs right and your algorithm
essentially needs to ensure that for
that every cycle is an even cycle okay
and that is exactly equivalent to
coloring it with two colors okay so um
we I obviously need to have a way of
stopping here in the sense that when you
have a cycle you you you're going to
come back and the cycle may may be fine
because it's an even cycle but you
obviously can't keep going around the
cycle without terminating in a computer
program so we if we're going to have to
do a recursive search which has
interesting termination conditions you
know as opposed to the
divide-and-conquer I or even the
iterative enumeration that we did where
it was pretty clear what the termination
condition was that the base case was
fairly straightforward because you came
down to a list of length one or you had
something where you broke things up to
the point where you had really small
problems and that corresponded to your
base case right but cycle detection
especially when you're doing recursive
traversal can be pretty tricky right and
we also of course as I said initially we
have to be able to to represent this
graph structure right um you could
represent it as a matrix right there's
you could say well I hate dictionaries I
I love lists and that's all I'm gonna
use for the rest of my life right not a
good idea but if you did that uh you
could certainly represent the graphs as
a as a matrix or a two dimensional list
it's called an adjacency matrix
representation and
want to write it out but effectively
your rows are all the nodes and your
columns are all the nodes and you you
have a 1 or a 0 in the appropriate
location based on whether there's an
edge between the row node and the column
no right and you can certainly do that
and it's most for most cases in most
cases it's a painful representation I do
deal with eye graphs are much easier to
deal with many especially when you want
to do traversal so we'll stick with the
graph structure all right um so let's
talk algorithms I want to take a
slightly different example it's similar
to what we have here but and I want to
talk about exactly how and an algorithm
would work and we kind of did that so
actually let's run it on this one and
then I'll write out what the pseudocode
for the algorithm would be I'm gonna
ignore a here you could imagine that
this particular algorithm would be run
on this degenerate case that corresponds
to a and you'd end up coloring this red
or blue so I'm just gonna go ahead and
and color this red and I'm not done with
my problem but I'm done with the
particular graph that corresponds to a
because a can't reach any other node in
the graph so you ought to be a little
bit careful and the code I'm going to
show you would need to be generalized to
take into account this this forest of
graphs okay because there's really a
bunch of different graphs that are
disconnected that are part of the
overall problem but if I start with B
then I get connectivity to all of the
remaining edges and so I'm good there so
let me go ahead and color this red and
so the way we described it we we say I'm
going to look for the neighbors of B and
so B is connected to just see in this
case and when I when I traverse an edge
what do I do with respect to the color
I flipped the color right I changed the
color there's only two colors so I can
think of it as flipping the color right
so I go then I Traverse an edge I need
to flip the color to do to blue right
and then I get to see and when I get to
see I then start traversing edges but
when I traverse an edge I need to flip
the color so this goes to are in the
case of D I can go to two different
places and so I need to go ahead and
Traverse to E and just for the heck of
it I'm gonna add another edge there
right because now you're going to see
how Y the code is gonna get a little
more complicated with respect to the
termination condition that I described
to you and the checks that we need to
perform with respect to the fact that we
wanted this graph to be 2 colorable okay
so when I write the way the way this
code is going to work is is I'm gonna
get to D and and with that color red and
I'm gonna now see for the first time
this is an interesting case for the
first time I'm gonna see that D has two
neighbors okay now I need to traverse
both of these edges that correspond to
these two neighbors in sequence I'm
gonna pick one and go with that and then
I'm gonna pick the other one
right in general there's two strategies
that you can follow and one of which is
called depth-first search and the other
is called breadth-first search okay so
I'm not gonna you're gonna see
effectively a depth-first algorithm and
I'm happy to tell you about
breadth-first in detail offline but i'll
mention what the difference is here so
you get a sense of what the differences
are and they're two fundamental search
techniques traversal techniques and the
depth first technique says I'm going to
I take D and I'm gonna pick one of its
neighbors and I'm going to go ahead and
say that effectively that that's the
only only neighbor and I'm going to
explore everything that I can get to
from that neighbor and then once I'm all
done and there's some termination
condition that happens I'm going to come
back and I'm going to look at this other
neighbor just wanting to ask
so so what would happen here in
depth-first search is the following D
would go to e and when I go through an
edge I need to flip the color right so I
get a B here at this point unlike what
we did early on when we did this
particular example or something similar
I what I did was when I saw our here
I colored F N and E both blue that's
effectively what I did remember that
right but now I'm actually doing
something different right this is a
different execution corresponding to
depth-first search right when I looked
at all of my neighbors including the F
case I remember we we had some color for
this and then we immediately took G H
and I and we colored them right that is
breadth-first search okay that is
looking at taking one step in all
directions that you can take and
essentially it's a frontier based
approach where I'm taking the the
frontier of my neighbors and pushing it
outward one step at a time right
contrast that with what we're doing here
you are going to take this a the
neighbor EE corresponding to D and then
you're not going to go to F you're in
fact going to go ahead and pick one of
the neighbors of E right and you might
even have in your representation E's
neighbor being D because you know yeah D
has a as a neighbor and so does e having
has D as a neighbor but you'll say oh
look look I don't need to go look at G
now in my depth-first search because D
is already been colored right so you
check that and then you say oh what has
not been colored I has not been colored
and and when I traverse an edge I need
to flip the color and I'm gonna go ahead
and put our in here alright and it's not
that you even go back to 2f now from D
you don't go back to D at this point you
now look at I and you do another
recursion corresponding to I and you say
okay what about eyes neighbors well II
may be first but you've already done
with the I'm gonna go ahead and I'm
gonna get to F and you do the flip and
you get B over here right I'm
you still don't go go back to 2d um you
look at F and you say I'm going to now
look at the the neighbors of F and maybe
you'll get a CH and you say this is our
then you go back and now for the first
time you're going to look at exhausting
the neighbors of a node that you've
actually reached and you've gone to one
neighbor for and so so at this point you
go and you make this R so now you come
back and you say I have i exhausted F's
neighbors and yes in the sense that all
the neighbors that I needed to look at
because they didn't have colors have
been exhausted and of course F had D and
I as neighbors and they already had
colors so I'm cool with that right I
don't need to and your I don't need to
touch them
now at this point I'm popping up because
of exhausted F's neighbors I'm going to
go back to where I came from
how did I get to F I did not get to F
from D I actually got to F from I right
so I'm going to go to I but the fact of
the matter is that I is done because I
didn't have to deal with E and I've
already I'm already done with F then I
go back to e same thing right then
finally I get back to D and I say oh now
I need to go look at F and I go and I
say Oh F is already colored so therefore
I'm done this is the simplest
representation that I can think of for a
graph that's also very efficient so I
messed with this graph quite a bit so I
want to claim that that dictionary
representation that says graph equals
open curly brackets and then eventually
close curly brackets corresponds to that
but it's kind of roughly corresponds to
that right and I can certainly write out
any graph representation in Python for
for any topological representation that
you give me but if you look at what
what's up there the important thing is I
want to show you or tell you about
the constituents of this rep so graph is
a dictionary okay a dictionary is a set
of key value pairs you represent sets in
Python using curly brackets right and
each of the key value pairs is
represented using some key :
Val and you see a set of key value pairs
because you see these commas between
them and so what you see here is the key
and the keys could be strings they could
be tuples um you you could have many
possibilities for keys and the key comes
first and in this case the key is the is
the string B okay and so that represents
the name of the node RB and the value is
it is usually a list and in this case
you have a list that has a single entry
in it because B only has one edge that
goes to C right and so a more
interesting case as you can see up there
is D and D connects to C F and E and so
you see D with C a and F right so that's
exactly what the point here is right
this algorithm would run differently if
you had a representation that was
equivalent from a topological standpoint
there's no order in the topology but i
chose c EF i you know it got typed
somewhere c EF and so the order of
neighbors is c followed by e followed by
F now that is if you took this list of
neighbors and you went from 0 1 2 in
terms of indices of that list there's
nothing that's stopping you from going
to 1 0 in which case you would go FEC
right or you could do some you know
crazy random ordering for the list
itself right
entirely up to you right it's
deterministic it's entirely up to you
but now you see how the order of the
values that corresponds to these lists
that give you the neighbors for every
node affects the execution of the
algorithm right now you do not want the
result of the algorithm yes or no this
graph is bipartite or not to be affected
by the order that you see there right
because when I draw a graph like this I
mean this graph is effectively something
that doesn't have order you can't really
say anything about the order of G H and
I in relation to F I mean there felt
that want us to the kind of the left of
it they're all two of them at the bottom
but that's not what this is about and so
obviously that graph regardless of
whether I drew it like this all right I
you know I drew it like that should be
by pie chart both of those graphs that
right that correspond to H and G with
their name slip are either bipartite or
not bipartite right so you absolutely
cannot have the algorithm being affected
by the order in which you see CEF or
what have you that make sense so you can
do a lot of operations on dictionaries
it's probably something that you want to
look at by looking at the code that we
have here and and looking at the code
from from graph analysis algorithms and
I'm happy to point you to other
literature but the way you access a
dictionary is looks a lot like accessing
the list so you can say something like
graph a and then you say something like
graph a if a is not a key in the graph
it would give you an error okay and but
you can you can you can certainly get
values back and you can also assign
values so graph a B would give it you
would give you
at this list see and you can go off and
you can say something like graph a b dot
append i and you could say d and if you
did that if you did graph a b dot append
d then that's effectively are taking
this and adding adding d to it so you
could mutate the graph if you wanted you
don't have to do that i in our code for
a bipartite graph checking because we're
not mutating the graph we're just
reversing the graph but you could
certainly do that
so the dictionaries are a pretty cool
representation encourage you to learn
about them and they're useful in in many
instances i clearly they replace lists
because you can certainly have keys as
integers right you can also have
negative numbers as keys there's nothing
that's stopping you from doing that and
you don't have to represent the negative
number on as as a string i mean you
could just have keys that are that go
from minus 22 to 27 what have you um so
hopefully you have some sense of what
this code is going to look like both
from a standpoint of the algorithm which
we executed a few times and from the
standpoint of this structure the
representation of the graph right so
let's take a look and at about ten lines
of code that corresponds to bipartite
graph coloring so it fits on a screen
okay and so this is a pretty tight code
it does exactly what we wanted to do in
the sense of it's going to determine
whether a graph is bipartite or not and
it has a bunch of arguments a graph is
what you imagined it to be
it's the input graph we have to start
from somewhere this graph has a list of
key value pairs the keys happen to be
the nodes you should never depend on the
keys being stored in a particular order
um these ways of saying you know you can
say things like graph keys
and this is going to give you back a
list of keys and it's possible that when
you say graphed our keys at one point in
the program you get the keys in a
particular order and when you say it at
a different part of the program you get
the keys in a different order okay but
all the keys won't change if there's no
bugs in your program you'll get the same
set of keys but they may be in different
order all right so you obviously want to
start a bit some node in the graph and
you're going to color it with a
particular color call it red I think I
had shaded than hatched here so sha
stands for shaded and hatch stands for
hatched but you can use what you want so
if you see the invocation here bipartite
graph color graph three starts with a
node this is an its coloring as a
dictionary and so we are also
representing not only the graph as a
dictionary but we're also representing
the mapping that we get namely the node
B was colored with red so B is up is is
a key in this coloring dictionary and
our red is is the color that's the value
right so you can represent mappings key
values or mappings right so so that the
coloring of a node is also a dictionary
right and so that's essentially what we
have so I'm going to start with it with
none of the nodes are colored so that's
why this is Mt and I'm going to start
with a and I'm going to start with the
color shaded which means that a is going
to be colored shaded or a is going to be
shade
okay and this is gonna return true or
false depending on whether I the graph
is bipartite or not and if it's true
then I'm going to get something
interesting with respect to the mapping
of nodes to colors that's my dictionary
coloring and otherwise I get false back
which an empty dictionary because then I
have something that's false I mean you
could imagine saying well there's a
problem case here you you you can color
all of these different nodes but I'm
just kind of stuck here because of that
five cycle but it that's kind of
indeterminate in terms of what the
colors need to be and so unless you were
actually going to go off and mutate the
graph and remove a node and and say this
is the friend you want to dump today and
then the rest of them are going to be
invited for dinner in that case you
could obviously return a coloring
dictionary even in this case of the
graph original graph not being bipartite
but most of the time you're probably in
a situation where if it's not bipartite
you don't return anything other than
false all right so let's take a look at
what each of these things do and then
you'll also get a sense of how we
manipulate dictionary structures so I'm
just going to explain very quickly each
line of code here so this pair of lines
of this pair of lines of code
essentially say something like well if
you've given me a starting node is just
a check on the input if the starting
node is not in the graph it's not a key
in the graph then I'm throwing up my
hands here this is not a graph it's not
a bipartite graph I can't give you a
coloring right so easy check not much
there this is an interesting check on
this essentially is going to check to
see whether on the particular node that
you have this is going to be done
recursively so anytime you arrive at a
node you have to check whether there's
already a color there or not
if there's no color then you move
forward and you color it and you also
move forward in the sense that you'll
probably I go ahead and if it has
neighbors you will Traverse their
neighbors right but if it has a color if
it's already in coloring that means it
already has a color right because the
keys that correspond to the coloring
dictionary are exactly the same in the
sense that they're their graph nodes and
they're also in the graph dictionary
right the mappings are F was completely
different and the coloring dictionary is
being grown as we speak or as we execute
but the the graph dictionary is actually
not mutated it's static okay and so this
check here says that I'm going to go
ahead and if it's not in coloring
great I'm going to go ahead and whatever
color I have I'm gonna go ahead and
color it with that right that's what
coloring start equals color does it just
colors the note okay and then that
effectively is adding the key value pair
a start comma color to the coloring
dictionary right that's what it does
otherwise um well I got two cases here
right this thing has already been
colored but I have two cases um I want
to color it with something different
from what it's already been colored
that's the problem that's a problem
that's exactly when we get a five cycle
and we throw up our hands so we're done
here we just say doesn't matter what
we've colored so far it's all garbage
you know this thing can be colored with
two colors given the constraints I have
so I'm just going to return false and an
empty dictionary right so anything that
coloring had in it I mean it's gone
right because it's bogus otherwise at
this recursion would say oh well I'm
going to return true for for this thing
here and I'm going to it's it has been
colored which means that you know have
it I don't want to do any more work on
it I mean I got this node here it's
already you know was already colored and
was consistently colored so if I don't
want to get into infinite loops I better
not you know start traversing nodes from
this node because we've already seen it
before
right so the fact that it's already
colored correctly is a termination
condition this is important I'm that it
says that I don't want to keep repeating
myself that is like going through the
cycle over and over right if you didn't
have that right that makes sense yeah
that's important
so now well this is a flip so this is
this there's no recursion there's no
procedure calls here this is just
flipping the color that make sense so
now at the last part which is at the the
part where I'm actually doing
depth-first search is the part which
says okay I got to the point now where
I'm essentially the the haven't done any
returns here right I've colored
with with color and and I've flipped the
color right so these two lines are
excuted no returns
these lines are executed and now I I've
clearly already colored starred and I
flipped the color and I'm going to go
ahead and make the recursive call
corresponding to the the neighbors of
start and all I have to do to look at
the neighbors of start is to return the
list corresponding to the value of graph
start remember I said graph a or graph
start is going to give you this this
list and I can go ahead and and append
to it and I'm not gonna mutate but I
could have done that and so that is
going to give me my list and I'm just
going to go through and you mer ate that
list in whatever order that it came to
me and start with I'm gonna call the
first element vertex because that's also
a vertex or node synonymous and I'm
gonna send in vertex here graph stays
the same vertex stays the same I've
modified coloring so I want to pass that
over and obviously I'm gonna pass new
color here because I've done the flip
right and if I ever I get something
that's false
that means I've founded an odd cycle and
I return false and then if everything
works out I return true in the coloring
okay so if I go ahead and run that if my
machine hasn't gone to sleep doesn't do
very much you know the first graph it
was not colorable I'd you can check
these results by yourself but this is
more the reason I'm putting this up is
to give you a sense of what the coloring
dictionary looks like right so just so
you get some more exposure to these
things so in this case you get a
non-empty coloring dictionary for the
second run so I ran it four times on
four different graphs you get a non
empty coloring dictionary it's true the
graph is bipartite and notice that the
order in which this coloring dictionary
was was what was created was certainly a
function of the execution of the
algorithm but I this order might
actually change if I keep running this
algorithm and if my machine had
different loads and so on and so forth
but it
you would always get true for any graph
representation that is bipartite or two
colorable but you you you have no
control over whether f hat comes first
or a hat comes first those could be
flipped alright
so never depend on the order of keys in
a dictionary okay
but certainly the existence of keys in a
dictionary you can or the nonexistence
you can depend on alright good so that's
really all I had to say any questions
all right excellent I want credit for
finishing one minute early